Hugs not bugs!
Or … embraces not… bacteriophages?
No…
Just HUG MORE!
It's good for you.
It's still cold and flu season, so obviously
people are concerned about their immune strength.
And now scientists from Carnegie Mellon have
found the simple hug might be a weapon on
the FRONT LINE OF YOUR IMMUNE BATTLE.
Humans are social creatures, we talk, we laugh,
we have intricate body language and we hug!!!
YaY!
I love a good hug, and this new science says
there might be more than one good reason to
get a nice squeeze.
It turns out your social feelings weigh far
more heavily on your physiology than you may
have thought.
According to a study published in last months
Psychological Science, people who are stressed
or have ongoing problems in relationships
would have trouble fighting off a cold virus.
The peeps at Carnegie Mellon found, those
with low QUOTE "social support" would succumb
to cold symptoms more quickly than those with
high social support.
They discovered this when they exposed 400
volunteers to cold viruses -- sidebar: they
signed up for this, but still, wow. -- and
talked to them about their relationships,
conflicts and if they'd received any hugs
that day.
Their findings suggest those who received
hugs from a trusted person were less stressed
and had less severe illness symptoms.
The researchers think this is because they
had a broader social support structure.
In the study, 75 percent of the volunteers
developed a cold, but those with higher social
support and frequent hugs recovered better;
more hugs, more better.
Firstly, I want to critique a little because
they didn't identify what a hug is.
The ass-out hugs aren't awesome.
It's got to be like, a real hug, right?
I mean, according to a 2003 study a 20 second
hug with a partner followed by 10 minutes
of hand-holding had significantly lower levels
of stress.
And a separate study says a 10 second hug
can provide a physiological response as well,
but they never really said.
I go for the long hugs.
Like… really long.
[[awkward pause]]
Studies have shown hugs lower blood pressure,
decrease feelings of loneliness, and improve
cardiac health, because when you hug someone,
the hormone oxytocin is released, which makes
both the hugger and the huggee feel good.
That oxytocin interacts with the body in a
number of ways, aside from being known as
the "love hormone" because it facilitates
bonding, it also boosts chemical release which
trigger immune system boosts.
That also drops the levels of stress hormones
in the body, which impair immune strength,
not to mention the other things stress can
do to the body.
This is extra interesting news, given the
recent release by the CDC…
This year's flu vaccine isn't exactly right.
Before each season, the scientists use statistics
and behaviors of influenza strains from previous
years, to determine which flu viruses will
dominate, and then create a vaccine for those.
Last year, the CDC says, the flu vaccine was
60-percent effective -- which is pretty good.
This year though, they missed one.
So get hugging.
In the end, giving your friend a hug might
be the better than sharing your vitamin C…
and we could all use a little more love, right?
Just make sure you're not already sick.
That might be counterproductive.
When it comes to hugs, is it better to give
or receive?!